إنها حقًا مسألة خيال
في البداية ، كان الأمر صعبًا بعض الشيء ،
لكن بعد كل تلك الرسائل
أولاً لم أكن أتوقع
أه مثل هذا النجاح ، ثم عندما رأيت
مثل
العرض الأول ، حققنا 50 مليون مشاهدة
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
التي تعرفها.  كان كل هؤلاء الأشخاص يقولون
شكرًا لك لقد نسينا كل شيء للحظة
التي نشعر فيها بسعادة كبيرة أثناء مشاهدة
العرض ،
لذلك أنا سعيد لأنك تعلم أنني أفعل ذلك
لأنني أريد
مشاركة حبي للموسيقى وإعطاء
الناس  وقت
ممتع لذلك لا توجد طريقة أخرى في الوقت
الحالي ،
لذلك أتخيل فقط أشخاصًا يرقصون في
المنزل مع أطفالهم مع صديقاتهم يقيمون
حفلة ، وهذه هي الطريقة التي
أفعل بها ذلك
، كما تعلمون ، كما أني أنظر إلى هذا
مذهل جدًا  أنت تعلم أنه من المدهش
[موسيقى] أن
عائدات أدائك هنا يوم
السبت ستذهب إلى منظمة اليونيسف
ودبي كيرز وهي منظمة
تدعى دبي تهتم
بالتعليم دون انقطاع
وتتتبع آثار 19 سرًا
على أطفال المدارس الذين تذهب إليهم
كيف حال الأطفال بنفسك كيف يتعاملون مع
كيف تتطورون كعائلة
خلال هذا الوقت الطويل ، حسنًا في الواقع ،
للمرة الأولى ،
أقضي الكثير من الوقت مع أطفالي ، وأعتقد
أنهم أشياء جيدة أو سيئة.  كنت سعيدًا
جدًا
بشأن المتعرج لأنهم على
الأقل يرون ذلك
أكثر قليلاً لأنني كنت دائمًا على متن طائرة
كانوا يعيشون في لندن ، لذا
فأنت تعلم أنني أخبرتهم أن المدرسة
مغلقة ،
فلماذا لا تأتي إلى هنا في دبي أه
ستتابعها عبر الإنترنت على أي حال ،
لذا من الأفضل أن تكون هنا حيث تكون الحياة طبيعية
تقريبًا ،
كما تعلم ، نعم ، هذا
ما حدث
وأنا سعيد بذلك.